in terms of finding is a person of
influence that you want to have look at
your work or give contact with I think
there's a fine line in LA so many people
are being pitched how aggressive do you
get because you don't want to turn a
little person off you know and when one
person was once ever items once asked
when you take no for an answer he said
when they call security
but I don't really subscribe to that the
real answer is first of all treat people
the way you would want to be treated so
don't be a jerk I mean for one thing you
have no monoi you have no idea how many
people in various circumstances will Jam
me up against a wall and start pitching
their story to me it's like mr. secure
mr. Zieg you usually hear this
okay well keep faded we open on the sky
and we see clouds we're panning down
we're pen down we're panning down we see
birds and preparing down we panicked
down renovate this aspire it's the
Empire State Building and we're down it
with a hundred and second four hundred
four hundred God you know no please no
and first of all when you're pitching
never pitch every beat every shot no
yeah it's the broad strokes but also you
should because you use that person
buying stories why are you pitching them
what's in it for them um you know it's
like but also no one likes to be pitched
in a you know in a social circumstance
or if they're giving a talk it's like do
I really wanna send our list with 20
minutes someone's story that I've known
for them from the first minute is awful
know about what you want to do is always
add first of all if you go to a vet
who you admire is speaking you remember
the rule of three
rule 3 is most people make the mistake
of immediately pitching or immediately
you know yeah I'm an actor you gotta
cast me out here's my hedgehog here's my
reel you don't know you have not
established relationship with that
person it's the first time you made from
an event you just say something truthful
maybe about their work but it has to be
specific it has to be you know there was
that scene in that movie you did with
who I was talking to his mother and you
know I had this really difficult
relationship with my mother when I
started seeing it open the door and me
somehow and when I have a conversation
with my mom and it changed our
relationship that's something that's
gonna resonate
that's something truthful and meaningful
from your heart but don't gush and don't
go on at length okay because there's no
the other people want to talk to this
guy the other part so then you go to a
second event with that person you see
and if you have a chance at the end
talking again say oh hi mr. so-and-so
you know last time when we spoken I told
you about my mom you said such and such
it really meant so much to me that that
you you really care you know or you say
something again it's like you know it's
thing and I just wanna let you know how
many how much that meant to me right
okay then you've got a third event the
third of it you run and then I say oh
gosh you keep running into each others
like we're swimming in the same aquarium
and you know it's like you know it's so
you've been so kind talking to these
last two times and there's something you
said last time we talked I really
applied it it really you know I made
this film or blub about whatever they
say no also I didn't I dunno I've read
in the trades that you're looking for a
Western and you know and basically the
conversations I'm having I just thought
I don't know if you'd be open to it by
Britain and Western I'd love to have my
representation send it to you if you'd
be open to that or you know whatever the
request is you say in a very respectful
manner you don't go out at length
you stop it yes or if he says no that's
fine you let it go the point is by then
so I gotta says that you're not a jerk
cuz you didn't push the button first
moment and secondly he's got enough
about you where he's intrigued about you
you know so that's that's the way you do
it or that's one way to do it another
way to do it by the way is if you go to
any event
you